[Música]
[Aplausos]
esto que os voy a ver ahora es la
conversación literal de una madre rusa
con su hijo que estaba luchando en el
frente ucraniano minutos antes de morir
abatido dice así hijo dónde estás papá
te quiere mandar un paquete de mamá cómo
me vas a mandar un paquete mamá que es
que estoy en ucrania que estamos en
guerra minutos después este soldado fue
abatido pero habéis oído bien en estos
momentos la mayoría de los rusos ni
siquiera saben que hay una guerra en
ucrania para hacer este vídeo hemos
hablado con muchísimos rusos que viven
dentro de la unión europea casi todos
están teniendo conversaciones totalmente
surrealistas con sus familiares que
viven en rusia no es simplemente que
tengan una visión o una narrativa
distinta de la guerra es que simple y
llanamente ni siquiera saben que hay
bombardeos en capitales ucranianas
[Música]
habéis visto esas imágenes vía satélite
que muestran ese convoy ruso de 60
kilómetros de largo esperando el norte
de kiev pues bien los rusos no lo han
visto literalmente viven en una realidad
paralela a la nuestra más aún después de
que el 4 de marzo de este año aprobarán
esta ley atentos
el parlamento ruso aprueba penas de
cárcel por informar sobre la guerra
falsa habéis oído bien ojo esto no es lo
que dice la propaganda ucraniana es
directamente lo que dice la ley rusa a
partir del 4 de marzo de 2022 decir que
rusia está en guerra abierta con ucrania
se considera fec news y las penas por
decirlo ojo pueden llegar a los 15 años
de cárcel y alguno pensará pues menuda
novedad desde cuando habido libertad de
expresión en rusia y si tenéis razón en
parte la diferencia es que antes si un
periodista decía algo incómodo con el
régimen solo se arriesgaba a pagar una
multa ahora puede terminar en la cárcel
por nada menos que quince años y diréis
y si no pueden hablar de la guerra de
que hablan entonces pues atentos porque
esto es lo que los rusos están viendo
estos días en la televisión italiana ya
aprobó jets 4 sold misioneras y es que
hitler haciendo territorio crain tal
cual como lo oís según la narrativa del
kremlin rusia no está en guerra con
nadie simplemente están mandando una
operación especial para luchar contra
unos terroristas neonazis que están en
el país y ya sea lo que diréis muchos
pero y los casi 200.000 soldados rusos y
los tanques y la aviación o cualquier
definición eso es una guerra abierta sin
embargo putin quiere que sus ciudadanos
piensen que se trata de algo mucho más
liviano y la pregunta es por qué
[Música]
quiero decir nos parece una
contradicción por un lado putin lleva
años encendiendo el fervor patriótico la
gloria del ejército de la gran guerra
patriótica que es como llaman la segunda
guerra mundial o de la gran madre rusia
puestos hacer propaganda no deberían
estar enseñando imágenes de los
gloriosos aunque rusos tomando hardcore
mensajes estilos somos los mejores
estamos ganando la guerra los ucranianos
que harán pronto guardia al enemigo
larga vida a rusia nuestra realidad es
la contraria putin quiere ocultar la
guerra a sus ciudadanos y la pregunta es
por qué cuál es la visión que tienen los
rusos ahora mismo de lo que está
ocurriendo hoy vamos a responder estas
preguntas pero antes muchos nos habéis
preguntado que cómo podéis colaborar con
el ejército de ucrania en este conflicto
pues bien el banco central de ucrania ha
abierto una cuenta de banco donde todos
podéis hacer donaciones ese dinero irá a
financiar la resistencia ucraniana y las
fuerzas armadas ucranianas esto no es
publicidad nadie nos paga por decir esto
y lo decimos meramente a título
informativo encontraréis todos los
enlaces en la descripción y ahora sí
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
y
la historia contada por y para los rusos
[Música]
ya sé lo que vais a pensar muchos en
visual politics es totalmente
imparciales este vídeo es claramente
propagando ucraniana sin embargo nada
más lejos de la realidad de hecho para
hacer este vídeo no hemos usado ninguna
fuente occidental lo que vais a ver
ahora es literalmente lo que los medios
de comunicación rusos están mostrando es
más para que nadie nos pueda acusar de
hacer traducciones sesgadas vamos a
poner todos los clips en versión
original subtitulada paréntesis
muchísimas gracias a svetlana quiche por
un lado y artem del canal y economy por
el otro por habernos ayudado a encontrar
y a traducir los vídeos fin del
paréntesis por ejemplo lo que vais a ver
ahora es lo que en rusia están poniendo
los niños en los colegios para
explicarles lo que está pasando atentos
a
y ser una región poco
por si alguno no le ha quedado claro van
ya en esta historia es una alegoría de
rusia y el malvado cold ya sería una
alegoría de ucrania y lo único que
querría rusia en esta historia es
quitarle el palo a ucrania es decir nada
de invasión ni de ataques con bombas
pues bien esto es lo que están viendo
los niños rusos en este momento y diréis
es adoctrinamiento pues eso lo podemos
discutir luego en los comentarios pero
lo importante es que en este momento nos
fijamos en la narrativa que llega a esos
niños rusos y ahora la pregunta es y los
adultos rusos que están viendo por la
televisión pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
guerra informativa
[Música]
durante años rusia avanzada posturas
cada vez más autoritarias ahora bien
nunca hayan llegado al nivel de una
corea del norte por ejemplo esta es la
televisión norcoreana
como podéis ver toda la imagen el
escenario el vestuario parece sacado de
otra época sin embargo esto es la
televisión rusa de hoy en día
como veis la televisión rusa es igual
que la televisión de cualquier otro país
democrático o al menos en apariencia
también tienen sus telediarios sus
tertulias políticas y hasta sus late
nigth de hecho hasta marzo de este año
el kremlin permitía que algunos medios
occidentales emitieron en rusia es decir
que tanto a la bbc como radio free
europe que son medios pagados por el
gobierno británico y el gobierno
estadounidense respectivamente podían
emitir noticias pro occidentales en ruso
cambio europa permitía la emisión de
rusia today y de sputnik news era algo
así como un pacto no escrito nosotros
aceptamos que hagas propaganda en
nuestro país si tú nos permite es hacer
lo mismo la guerra ha cambiado toda esta
lógica
[Música]
europa ha cortado en seco las emisiones
de rt y de sputnik news así que rusia ha
contraatacado cerrando radio free europe
y bbc pero no vamos a hablar en este
vídeo de esta guerra informativa porque
podríamos discutir sobre hasta qué punto
es bueno o malo permitir que rusia
tuviera medios de propaganda en europa
pero de nuevo esto es otro tema para
otro vídeo porque hoy nos vamos a
centrar en los medios rusos dentro de
rusia y lo cierto es que el kremlin no
se ha limitado a cerrar los medios
occidentales la censura total está
llegando a todas partes por ejemplo
hasta marzo de este año rusia llegó a
tener algunas televisiones críticas con
el kremlin vale que no eran muchas y en
honor a la verdad no estaban libres de
persecución judicial incluso de multas
pero hay que reconocer que el kremlin
permitía cierta crítica en los medios de
comunicación ese es el caso por ejemplo
de moscú que se traduciría como el eco
de moscú esta era una radio propiedad
del grupo gazprom si habéis oído bien
dentro de rusia gazprom también es un
grupo de comunicación en cualquier caso
como si era una de las radios más
críticas con putin han conseguido
sobrevivir en un régimen cada vez más
autoritario pero y de prensa que acaba
de aprobar el kremlin y la duma ha
cambiado las reglas del juego la radio
liberal e como tierra después de que la
quiten su frecuencia de onda veréis
muchas veces cuando analizamos los
sistemas políticos de distintos países
cometemos un error porque pensamos que
hay dos categorías cerradas democracia o
dictadura en realidad el autoritarismo
es un espectro corea del norte sería el
extremo rusia todavía no está ahí pero
está claro que cada vez es más
autoritaria y esta ley es todo un paso
de gigante hacia una dictadura pura y
dura
para que os hagáis una idea a partir de
ahora cualquier periodista ruso que se
salga ligeramente del guión del kremlin
se enfrenta a penas de cárcel de hasta
15 años y si habéis oído bien 15 años de
cárcel es decir que no estamos hablando
de una multa ni de que te echan de tu
empresa o de que te
cancelen en twitter hablamos de 15 años
de cárcel y esto no es algo que diga la
prensa occidental es literalmente una
ley que acaba de ser aprobado por la
duma rusa así que ahora mismo todas esas
televisiones rusas que parecen legítimas
y plurales están diciendo el mismo
mensaje
en stony brook
pues es muy simple traen el exacto según
la narrativa rusa todos los ucranianos
son nazis y eso incluye por supuesto al
presidente volodymyr cell en sí que por
cierto es de ascendencia judía
y diréis vale y si fuera verdad de
verdad hay nadie se lucran ya y la
respuesta es que sí evidentemente en un
país de 44 millones de habitantes donde
prácticamente toda la población está en
armas al grupos de neonazis y grupos de
hooligans ahora bien hay una gran
diferencia entre decir que en ucrania
hay grupos neonazis o decir que toda
ucrania está en manos de batallones
nazis y por eso la propaganda rusa tiene
un doble discurso una cosa es lo que la
propaganda rusa dice a los que vivimos
fuera de rusia es decir este es el
mensaje de rusia today o de sputnik news
los medios 20 stream han pasado por alto
el hecho de que el batallón de azov que
es un componente oficial de las fuerzas
armadas de quien tiene una ideología pro
nazi como veis esto es una noticia
relativamente creíble para alguien que
vive en un país con una mínima libertad
de expresión hay batallones neonazis en
ucrania pues seguramente significa esto
que todo el gobierno de ucrania es un
contubernio fascista amante de hitler
creo que ni siquiera el más ardiente pro
ruso podría creerse algo así al menos si
vive fuera de rusia
[Música]
ahora bien los rusos ya no pueden ver
nada que no esté controlado por el
kremlin no pueden ver las intervenciones
de celestín y todas esas imágenes de vía
satélite con una hilera de tanques al
norte de kiev así que esta es la
retórica que están utilizando ahora
mismo en todas las tertulias políticas
y por supuesto ninguna televisión rusa
veréis las imágenes de ninguna ciudad
ucraniana destruida es más los medios
rusos llaman a esto simplemente una
operación especial en las nuevas
repúblicas de dónetsk y luján a duras
penas se dice nada sobre los bombardeos
de ciudades que todos hemos visto en
occidente y ya sé lo que se estaría
preguntando muchos pero porque putin
quiere ocultar la guerra a los rusos es
decir se supone que esto es una cruzada
contra los malvados nazis no sería más
lógico que quisiera mostrar al glorioso
ejército ruso demostrando esos fascistas
ucranianos quién manda pues lo cierto es
que no y ahora mismo vamos a ver por qué
la paz es la guerra la guerra es la paz
puede que sorprenda pero esta no es la
primera vez que el kremlin ocultó una
guerra durante la invasión de afganistán
la de los años 80 no la última la unión
soviética hizo todo lo posible por
evitar usar la palabra tierra en los
medios de comunicación en este caso se
hablaba de ayuda o de intervención
internacional pensando bien las guerras
se ganan o se pierden sin embargo las
operaciones especiales o las
intervenciones internacionales son
conceptos mucho más vagos dicho de otra
forma que a diferencia de los americanos
los soviéticos nunca han vistos
ejércitos saliendo humillado de
afganistán porque pues porque no puedes
perder una guerra si nunca has declarado
una guerra
está todo pensado
[Música]
pero esta no es la única razón por la
que el kremlin quiere ocultar esta
guerra pensando así durante años putin
ha agitado el fervor patriótico en
anteriores vídeos de visual políticos
hemos contado como putin ha llegado
incluso a construir una especie de
catedral dedicada al ejército catedral
que tiene incluso vidrieras dedicadas a
la gran guerra patriótica que ya sabéis
que es como llaman en rusia a la segunda
guerra mundial el nacionalismo en este
país está presente incluso en la música
popular es más si queréis profundizar un
poco más en la cultura rusa os
recomiendo que busquéis música de estilo
hard base es decir es el techno ruso al
igual que en españa tenemos a los canis
en rusia tienen a los llamados gopnik
que también tienen su propia subcultura
y es muy interesante si escucháis este
tipo de música encontrareis letras como
party like stalin o rusia es mi patria o
la gran nación eslava vamos que incluso
en las discotecas rusas hay loas a la
madre rusia sin embargo hay una
diferencia entre el nacionalismo ruso y
el americano por ejemplo
[Música]
los estudiosos de nacionalismo lo
clasifican en dos tipos cívico y étnico
el nacionalismo cívico se basa en una
ideología unos valores y un estilo de
vida compartido estamos o la propia
unión soviética- serían ejemplos de este
nacionalismo cívico es decir los
soviéticos no estaban luchando
simplemente por la gloria de rusia sino
por la revolución proletaria sin embargo
cuál es la ideología de rusia hoy en día
es decir que defiende putin se trata de
un sistema político concreto pues por
supuesto que no el nacionalismo ruso
actualmente se basa en un concepto
étnico la gran nación eslava bajo esta
narrativa los ucranianos y los rusos son
el mismo pueblo así lo explicaba el
mismísimo putin en una carta que
escribió a principios de este año y
tiene mucha lógica que piensan así a fin
de cuentas rusos y ucranianos han
convivido juntos durante siglos hay
millones de ucranianos viviendo en rusia
y miles de matrimonios mixtos el ruso
medio ha estado de vacaciones en crimea
tiene amigos en kiev o incluso habla
algunas palabras de ucraniano y todo
esto explica noticias como esta naval ni
llama a los rusos a protestar todos los
días contra la invasión de ucrania para
quien no lo conozca alexéi navalni es el
mayor opositor político de putin ahora
mismo está en la cárcel y está pidiendo
a todos los rusos que sigan protestando
en las calles
[Música]
en estos momentos hay miles de rusos
encarcelados por haber participado en
manifestaciones contra la guerra pero no
os equivoquéis estas protestas no son
pro occidentales naval ni es el primero
que siempre ha defendido la invasión
rusa de crimen ha pasado bien el
nacionalismo ruso se basa en la idea de
que los ucranianos son hermanos de los
rusos sin embargo el ejército ruso está
masacrando a ucranianos es una situación
totalmente distinta de lo que fue la
ocupación de crimea es decir en el año
2014 cuando rusia invadió la península
de crimea apenas hubo bajas putin tomó
un territorio donde era más que
bienvenido la situación de ahora sin
embargo es completamente distinta y lo
que muchos rusos muchos de ellos
nacionalistas hasta la médula y
partidarios de putin se preguntan ahora
mismo espero porque estamos masacrando a
nuestros propios hermanos
[Música]
por ejemplo lifebook boris es un canal
de youtube creado por un ruso donde
hablan y se utilizan un poco la cultura
rusa nada más estalló la guerra en
ucrania boris decidió despedirse de su
audiencia con estas palabras tengo
familia amigos y parientes viviendo
tanto en ucrania como en rusia me
gustaría decir que todos mis conocidos
están a salvo pero sería una mentira
life of paris youtuber ruso estonio como
veis a putin le interesa esconder que
hay una guerra a toda costa y la
propaganda rusa está tratando de evitar
cualquier imagen de kiev y en todo
momento se habla de operaciones
especiales o incluso de operaciones
antiterroristas y por eso el kremlin
necesita controlar el mensaje más que
nunca eso explica esta nueva ley de
prensa que ha acabado con el poco
pluralismo que quedaba en rusia la
pregunta ahora es cuánto puede durar
esta mascarada es decir por mucho que
vladimir putin controle sus medios de
comunicación es casi imposible ocultar
una guerra a los rusos que encima tienen
amigos en ucrania de verdad es posible
esconder todo una guerra con un país
vecino ante la opinión pública creéis
que esta nueva estrategia de censura va
a funcionarle a putin en el largo plazo
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
y como siempre no olvidéis que aquí en
visual politics sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribirse a
este canal y dadle a campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones y os ha gustado este
vídeo darle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]